it's been four long years since Maria
castiano has seen her son she lives in
the Philippines he's in Vancouver of
course I missed him a lot I want to hug
my baby but it's not just the Pacific
Ocean that was in the way for this
couple it was Canada's covid-19
protocols because of the quarantine the
yeah all that stuff now global news has
learned the federal government is
looking at dropping the covid-19 vaccine
requirement for entering the country
it's about time yeah it could happen as
early as September 30th when border
measures extended in June are set to
expire the vaccine mandate that they
were enforcing involved two vaccine
doses which were over a year old
presumably the government's just decided
that now is the time to transition into
something resembling normalcy a source
also confirms the use of the awry live
can app which requires passengers to
fill out vaccination information before
entering Canada would become optional
the plan still needs to be finalized by
prime minister Justin Trudeau before it
can be announced this comes after
pressure from the tourism industry
Airlines border communities and even
International airline passengers I think
this time right time to get rid of that
things many Saw long wait times and
major backlogs at airports partially due
to vaccine certificate checks now Canada
is following in the footsteps of many
other countries that have already
scrapped nearly all of their covid-19
rules Canada is now virtually alone last
week Australia and New Zealand dropped
the rest of their pandemic mandates
Europe and the UK had done it for quite
some time now the United States still
requires vaccination for entry but as of
now it's not yet known whether it'll
follow shoot and drop that mandate at
the same time as Canada Carmel coromali
Global News